let's go - this is always a risk but
let's go to Ari who's in the notes as
obsessed with Iran and Russia ari what's
going on what do you have for me today
they David sorry about last time I had
some technical difficulties okay I
forgot about it already yeah okay yeah
and I know you're sick of this topic by
now but I just want to just do everybody
else talks about the Venezuela thing I
think you people been a little bit too
hard on you because you're obviously
anti-regime Jane the only thing is that
I'm when you talked about the left-wing
apologetics as it pertains to Maduro I
got that I don't really see it that much
in terms of the prominent voices now I'm
not talking about people on twitter
twitter who apologize you know who are
apologists for Putin Assad and the rest
of the rest of that ilk but as far as
you know even people like progressive
more progressive politicians like Roy
Khanna obviously Sam Sam Cedar Cove the
secular talk I I see them clearly saying
that you know Maduro is bad but we
should not be involved in regime change
and I think that when given the fact
that you have people like jumbled and
almost blatantly saying that were or
basically this is the reason why this
matters to us is a because of natural
resources
yeah the narrative emanating from the
American context that you like shouldn't
be as much well here's a list of Maduro
as crimes against humanity but rather
more module is bad we opposed the
authoritarian rule but let's not get
involved here because it hasn't worked
out so well in the past so I yeah that's
my that's my position so tell me where
we disagree well I'm just saying I think
that you know you know when you're
talking about why people were
criticizing Bernie I think that the it
was more the optics of it it is kind of
playing into the hands of some of the
new the perception was yeah here's the
problem here's my problem with that Ari
that is where you go into an oppressive
restriction on speech because what
you're basically saying like think about
this for a second Ari you called me you
said listen the position of I think you
listed Kyle and the majority report
people you go the Kyle the majority
report people say Maduro is bad and
they're against regime change David
Pakman writer thinks maduro's
and he's against regime change re who's
normally obsessed with Iran and Russia
when he calls in is thinks Maduro is bad
and he's against regime change and
Bernie said that Maduro is bad and he's
against regime change but Bernie saying
it is dangerous because it plays into
the neoliberal narrative of john bolton
who wants to take their oil that so
you're basically think bernie shouldn't
comment or bernie should say something
that's not really his view either way is
problematic it's not even i mean i'm he
can say whatever he wants and he should
be able to say you know we should we
should implement regime change maybe no
but my points here's my real specific
point and here's the question i got for
you
you've identified that you agree with me
and with bernie sanders and it sounds
like with sam cedar and with kyle
kolinsky Maduro is bad were against us
led regime change but you said you
understand why it's problematic for
bernie to just say what he believes
which matches exactly what you believe
so what should bernie do should bernie
not comment or should he comment but say
something that's not what he believes
cuz the three options are Bernie says
what he believes Bernie says something
he doesn't really believe or Bernie
keeps his mouth shut
which one should Bernie do so first I
would say just bear wasn't here I would
say that first of all I'm not hundred
percent convinced that Bernie
necessarily believes that I think it's
he's a politician and he's playing ball
a little bit in my opinion I could be
completely wrong but I think that's my
I've seen the evidence that's how Bernie
Sanders operates so unless you can
present my evidence I don't think that's
how Bernie operates I mean I think I
think that's how all politicians operate
personally that is not nothing to about
Bernie Sanders specifically but I would
say that what I would have wanted to see
from a progressive stance a progressive
politician is more emphasis on the on
the you know on the regime change aspect
that's all it's not that I personally I
found his suite to be fairly innocuous
compared to benign compared to the other
guys like secular talk I think they were
blowing it out of proportion but there's
a shred of it that I on
where they're coming from just from you
know emphasizing that there is
propaganda emanating from our side to to
implement regime change in a lot of
different places that's that's really it
sounds like basically re me and Bernie
we're all in the same page but you think
that the vocabulary Bernie used slightly
over emphasized one thing and under
emphasized a different thing in a way
that you're not exactly in line with but
you basically agree with that man me
that's right well we're all on the
wrongs more or less on the same page I
think but I think the way you say stuff
batters I just I'm not trying to you
know do restrict anybody speaker but I'm
saying you know I think the way you
present stuff does matter as far as you
know you know he's an influential guy so
I just I think he could have done a
little bit better that but it's nothing
that I feel like I'm you know that I'm
you know I think that it's horrible in
any way that I think it was fairly
denied so that's all I that that's all
I'm getting to but all right okay re so
it sounds like really everybody's doing
mostly a good job according to re all
right re great to hear from you we will
I am sure hear from you again that does
it for today we will take calls again
and I really appreciate everybody
calling it